[Music]
hello and welcome to dw's international
talk show quadriga where today
we're talking about the 1000
battle-hardened islamic state fighters
and their families from germany some of
them
are now on their way back home many are
already here
following is's collapse in syria and
iraq
to both men and women and among them are
vicious killers and war
criminals of those who have returned a
number
are already on trial what should germany
do with them
should they answer for their crimes and
be sent to prison should social workers
help them
integrate back into society into
neighborhoods schools
workplaces
islamic state terror today just how
dangerous
are returning is fighters i'm brian
thomas and joining me here in berlin to
talk about that
is amir misawi he works for media
outlets here in germany and in iraq
he says some is returnees are dangerous
but more dangerous
is the updated ideology they bring with
them
alan poser is a commentator for the
daily newspaper developed
he argues if we want other states to
take back their citizens who we consider
terrorists
then we have to take back our citizens
who have committed
terrorist acts and kristen hellberg is
a featured mideast analyst in a number
of european publications she points out
is is militarily defeated but not
ideologically the west
must help the kurds in dealing with the
jihadists
a warm welcome to all of you and to
those of you joining us from around the
world
kristin if we could um start with you
you've also written
two books about this topic about is
about syria
you've spent a lot of time in the
country let's get a a demographic
of our average is fighter jihadist
who is he and what drew him to fight in
syria to fight in iraq
well it's not that easy because behind
the 1050
german is fighters there are 1 000
personal stories
they are quite young the majority of
them they have radicalized
very quickly usually over the internet
so some of them are converts
german citizens converts some of them
are migration they have a migration
background in germany but
i think what generalizes them would be
that they feel
alienated from german society they felt
that this is not their country this is
what we hear from
women for example who left for the
caliphate who
said that i don't want to educate my
children in this country i feel i'm not
part of this country
personal frustration maybe as a muslim
feeling you know
this new anti-muslim ideas in many
german citizens so this is a general
question of
why did these citizens german citizen
not feel at home in germany and then how
did they radicalize you know this is a
this is basically an internet problem
an internet problem we'll get back to
that aspect let's talk about the
alienation first alan if you could pick
up on that
is it a failure of integration um into
german society
is it a result of the rise of the right
what's behind
so many young people sympathizing with
is and even going to
fight in iraq and syria for them now
returning home
no i don't think it's neither a failure
of integration
although integration has failed in some
respects
nor is to do with being discriminated
against nor really
is it all that many people i mean um
we have had homegrown terrorism here
think of the
so-called red army faction the movement
of the 2nd of june
people of my generation who went
underground and they had
thousands of sympathizers hundreds of
people who went underground helped them
in all sorts of organizations and they
were neither alienated nor were they
uh you know converse to islam or
anything so
you disagree disagree with kristin you
think they're not alienated
they may be alienated but it's not
because they're being discriminated
against
i think it's something that happens that
can happen to you quite
quickly in as as a person said over the
internet
suddenly you find something that seems
to explain all
your problems and and gives you a
purpose in life
and and off you go and um you know we
had this with with
is interesting because the raf the red
army faction on the one hand you have
these
highly intelligent um intellectuals
and on the other hand you had sort of
semi-criminal careers
who and they they bonded and it's quite
similar with is you have these
semi-criminals or real criminals and but
then you also very intelligent
converts often um who who take the
ideology of islam which they've half
understood and convert it into something
which reminds me
again more of european terrorism
than of anything you know from history
70s well the similarity is certainly
the danger emir you say that these
individuals these young men
are dangerous but more dangerous is the
ideology can
can you expand on that exactly because i
think when we defeated
uh al qaeda military qaeda is still
existing till now
and i think this uh give an example how
the ideology is still existing with that
people
that detainees when they come back here
not all of them of course but
most of them they are still dangerous
and they have
equipped with the military training they
equip themselves with a ideology they
just found that image imagination that
we can live in a state uh uh
governed by sharia this is possible okay
the the the project is filled but still
the hope is still existing and i think
we should just be careful who are we
going to bring back
which case he is how distance is he from
this that ideology i think
the most dangerous is the woman because
they are more radicalized than the man
and i think the combination between what
back to the question
uh why they uh left germany and i think
the combination of the
uh individual problem uh
personality personal problem and the
international jihadism
uh it is not a fundament just in germany
look to whole europe
it's uh worldwide a problem when this
fix in one time in one place this is the
toxic
brew isn't it the personal problems and
the ideology of christians
to pick it up actually what ellen just
said because it's i think it's very
important i would very much agree on
that i think
that jihadi idolatry is some kind of a
youth movement as it was 30 years ago
with the left
so at that time by the way if you wanted
to step
up against the society as a whole you
were looking for justice justice as a
major feature if you talk to extremists
it's all about creating a just
state a just order so at that time it
was left as marxist
idea and now it's islam so it's really
some kind of a fashion as well a youth
fashion that is
very easily promoted through the
internet that gets to these people
because it attracts them it attracts
them and
you pointed out uh that that um it is
in fact young women and amir that's what
the new research is showing
is that young women are especially
attracted why
are would they be especially attracted
or young women particularly
um optimistic or what quality do they
have
the quality of women is kind of
advertising for the
i especially women coming from western
countries just to get to say
for the local is members look that
people have
everything in europe but they left them
back and they come to us that give us
uh credibility that we are in the right
time in the right
track and beside of this
they married with fighters also it is
something interesting and i think when
we look for one example we said
we saw a woman married a
is fighter went to syria he killed in a
fighting and
she came back to germany and uh
married another guy and went against uh
second time there this is a this is an
example show you how dangerous they are
you've interviewed a number of is um
women uh women the the brides of the is
fighters
um was there an attraction to the
anti-feminist
message that is part of the uh is
ideology what what drew them in the
women you talked to
well in the end of the day that women
live
in a kind of sharia
imagination that the woman pray play
the role as a housewife she should serve
her man
and she should keep herself in house she
served the religion she served the god
when she served her man this is a kind
of anti
you can say it anti-feminism like this
but
also with the criminal energy inside
because
they look to others as unbelievers
and they do not accept even to talk with
someone
i came from iraq and i talked with her
she said i don't want to talk with you
because you are
unbeliever something like this it's our
perspective okay
you've been you've been rolling your
eyes a bit uh christian i mean that's
true but
we shouldn't forget that one-third of
the is fighters already came back and
among them a lot of women who were
completely disillusioned
because they went there they thought the
caliphate was some place some ideal
place you know where the people would
live in
in respect and injustice and everybody
would have his place and she would have
an important role to play
and they were in fact exploited they
were exploited or they felt that this is
not the place that they were dreaming
of so they came back so not all of them
are these very ideologically
convinced persons we have to admit and i
think the women that are very convinced
of it they feel that they have a certain
place they have an important role to
play
they they are respected as a woman they
are against
this uh sexualized role of women in the
west you know they would criticize this
obviously because we have a
problem with a german roma and a role
model of women something
the left looks at too as well the
sexualization of the west
feminism for them would be something you
know that uh it
doesn't help them in their rights but
something that they feel that they would
lose their dignity
okay from their perspective let's meet
one of these women right now among those
returning from the battlefields of syria
and iraq
as we've been discussing are not only
hardened warriors but also women and
children the wives sons and daughters
of those combatants one woman attempting
to get back to germany
is an is wife she's now living in a
syrian refugee camp with her son
son she says she was forced into the
situation
and was a captive bride of islamic state
marooned somewhere in northern syria
tens of thousands of people live in this
overcrowded refugee camp
among them children wounded men and
women and perhaps
islamic state militants most want to
return to their home countries as
quickly as possible
one is zainab giergen she used to live
in berlin with her turkish husband
on a visit to turkey he forced her to
accompany him to syria where he joined
the is
according to her statements now her
husband is dead
[Music]
as it's horrible the crimes isis
committed in the name of islam
[Music]
i'm hoping i'll be allowed to come back
to my beloved home country germany
her son was born during the war now
she's hoping the worst is behind her
cruel things happened there women and
children have no value at all
women were horribly mistreated by isis
whether complicit or not should isis
followers get a second chance
amir what do you think there is she
telling the truth and how do you go
about ascertaining something like that
you know this is a standard answer what
we get
when we interview that these people that
they don't have
they don't accept the islamic state
ideology and so on but i think this is
we should really think about what they
say because i
i for for me personally i do not believe
her because
she she lived in islamic state till 2019
for almost four years
that four years there were many many
chances to lift
uh the state and to go to surround
himself and
we saw in many cases by the way that
women really do not accept islam it's
difficult to leave and they
it's difficult but they managed to to to
to go back
but in the end of the day um we should
think
about who are going to come back in
which cases
and how distance has uh or they have for
the
ideology and really it's it's need a lot
of work
it's the it needs evidence uh when you
go to the court you should bring
black and white the kurds who are um in
control of much of the area where these
um
former is people are being held so it's
very difficult to get that kind of
evidence alan what do you think how
should we deal with these cases
should they be tried in syria so these
should these individuals once they
return here
be subject to german law um
well well look i i'm glad that we have
this problem because remember how
we pointed the finger at the united
states about guantanamo they had similar
problems there these people have been
found on the battlefield they were
obviously
they had been fighters but you know you
couldn't prove it what to do with them
so they dumped them in a sort of extra
legal
a place called guantanamo we are doing
the same with these people we're saying
to the kurds
you hang on to them we don't want them
for whatever reason
now uh we can do that but then we have
or that ought to be or to climb off our
high horse with regards to guantanamo
what i think since we have put ourselves
on this
position that we say everyone deserves a
fair trial that
a person like the the woman young woman
who just heard
should come back to to germany and make
her case and she'd be charged with
membership of
a foreign terrorist organization
paragraph 129
a and it's two or three years in prison
um and she can make her case
and and see if if if if if one can
believe her
i think that's that's one option there's
another compelling uh issue here and
that's what to do about the children
what about her little boy that's very
important because most of these children
are very young age they are between one
and five years old so really to leave
them
in syria and iraq means that we are
creating a next generation of
young people who have not entered school
who are not educated who have only
learned to fight so we can really not
afford this so to take care of the
children
really we need a whole set of measures i
think inside germany we need the
jurisdiction of course we have a state
of law
we have everything we need we have the
laws that we need we have to find proof
but it's not
it's not that difficult in terms of
terrorist organization because you have
to prove that they actively supported a
terrorist organization
which sometimes it's easier because you
find evidence on the internet because
they themselves post
with victims and with what they did so
this helps in something
easy to be honest it's not easy but it's
i'd like to i'd like to jump in and ask
what to do with the children though as
we as we
you know we have the combatives it's
clear this is only one point the other
thing
are social workers the only thing it's
like the other thing is psychological
uh workers obviously who work with these
children who try to
de-radicalize them who try to give them
a childhood to try to set them on zero
and start again basically
we have to work very closely with the
families of these former is
members the families of the women for
example maybe the grandparents who could
take off
here in germany this is what's happening
actually there is some experience with
this from the last
few years when they when they first came
back the first few members uh i mean how
do
other um islamic countries deal with
this problem other arab countries deal
with the problem of foreign fighters
that are returning home
their wives their children do is it
different in
egypt for example or saudi arabia
how they approach this issue well
um they have also kind of re
derecolorizing
programs for example in saudi arabia we
were they
implementing also theoretical
personnel and also social worker and to
get their
detainees uh in morocco for example in
tunisia but
i think just to go a step back for the
question
what we how we should behave with that
phenomenon i think the the most
important question
are we going to face the next generation
of is
i hope that i'm wrong but the question
is yes because when i see
the situation in the ground that the
politician and the situation and
politics situation
in syria now or syria and iraq they're
making the same mistakes
before and before 2014 uh
crushing undeveloped country without
hope uh
um using the cart in the in a strong
term
and i think people in the end of the day
they need
prosperity they need a hope they need
they need to have
um a kind of a light in the end of the
tunnel
to isolate them from the is members
but when they come together in this
social situation
the is will have grown up again again
it's like a dormant virus that's waiting
to emerge
under the proper conditions um this is
exactly what i mean when i'm saying we
have not
fought it ideologically if you're
talking about really defeating isis on
an ideological base you have to think
about the reasons why people turn to is
and the conditions of life that they are
facing so we've determined that
they could be personal as well as this
was about the europeans we're talking
about the regional if you look at syria
if you look at iraq if you look at egypt
you have really the ground is prepared
for any extremist organization to come
back because we have to
take care about education about
political parties when you say we are
you talking about
dignity internationally talking about
the international community who is
supposingly fighting isis but only on a
military
level which is not enough because we
have to take care about the regions
that we the west destroyed for example
the city of raqqa lies in ruins
or libya right one and a half years
after the liberation of rakhine still
lies in ruins it's full of minds people
are displaced
around raqqa they cannot come back they
don't have a dignified life
they cannot politically participate nor
the sunnis in iraq
nor don't even think about it in syria
think about the prisons
also turkey's involved in the region you
can't just point your finger at the west
can you no
you can't point because europe really
hasn't learned the lesson from the arab
arisings they they misunderstand
dictatorship with stability this is what
we see in egypt if you put a young
activist into
egyptian prisons this is really what
create makes him an extremist
in the next would you agree that the
west has a special responsibility to
go back to syria to iraq stabilize them
in a way
that uh precludes islamic state from
rising again
yes i would agree um one of the big
problems in in iraq was for instance
when the americans were there and they
had this um
after al-qaeda arose partly from
members of the old army and the bath
party and so on and the americans
under general petraeus had this surge
and the arab awakening
they defeated al-qaeda not only military
but also politically but then the
americans left
and al-qaeda comes back and the bath
patai comes back
as in the form of is going now in
afghanistan exactly
so it's always there we always you know
we we always think oh we go in we we
head together and then we go out again
it doesn't work like that let's let's
pick up on this
and and so the islamic state diaspora if
you will the
so-called islamic state has been crushed
on the battlefield
in syria and iraq on the battlefield it
is but it's far from a
spent force in other countries like some
in africa
and as far as field as indonesia
isis fighters were on the advance that
was in 2014
when the terrorist organization took the
city of raqqa syria
it was the start of five years of war
ending with thousands dead and captured
now isis's last fortification the
village of bagooz on syria's border to
iraq
has fallen the islamic state's caliphate
appears to be in an end
with help from the international
alliance combating isis in the middle
east
but observers warn that isis still poses
a danger
the extremist militants have gone
underground in iraq and elsewhere
including the leader abu bakr
al-baghdadi
the terrorist militia can still mobilize
thousands of fighters and tens of
thousands of sympathizers
the idea of the islamic state lives on
since the summer of 2018 around 250
attacks have been made outside of syria
[Music]
how dangerous is isis now
[Music]
amir what do you think is is more
dangerous now
than it was prior to its defeat in some
ways
i believe yes because we are talking
about
million of us dollars investing in a
normal economy that he
has managed before they defeated in iraq
and syria
to in turkey in europe they are the
money is there the financing
system is going on underground and
beside of this
the slave sales still active we have
about 50 attacks in iraq
still till now every month
and beside of the fact that is would
like
to show that they are still existing
they are trying
to to make some attacks here and there
just to say we are still strong but i
think
in the end of the day the dangers will
be less or more
depend on the question how how we are
determined
to to manage with this problem in the
long term not in the short term
just putting bombs as you say uh social
eco
uh political uh engagement there's a
there's a long term strategy that we
need to have but alan
it also needs to be a short-term
strategy we've had the christmas market
attack here
wasn't is um directly but an
is-affiliated individual
are german authorities prepared for is
attacks here
in germany well you know if i say yes
then tomorrow a bomb goes off and and
it's
difficult you can't be prepared can you
because i mean
we've seen all the mistakes that were
made with the christmas market attack
here and it could
could have been prevented but it's easy
to say that after the event now i think
german
the german authorities are i mean we
never hear about the many attacks that
they foil we only hear about the ones
that get
that go through i s claimed
responsibility for the christmas market
they're like a franchise aren't they i
mean a bomb goes off they say oh it was
us
and um or the people who laid the bomb
said oh we're islamic state
you you never know but look we're going
to have to live with terror
for the rest of our lives uh that's for
sure and um
we're just going to have to get used to
it and and
react from time to time at the same time
i agree with amir totally a long-term
strategy look what's happening in in
sudan
or and in algeria people want democracy
people who want to
total change now are we going to leave
them in the lurch are we going to do
something
are you arguing for a return of a strong
american presence to the region
something that under the current
administration would be very difficult
um not only american european i mean
it's our neighborhood
it's not even america's neighborhood i
mean algeria used to be a member of the
european union when it was part of
france
but it depends what kind of return we're
not talking about returning them for
regime change we're not talking about
going back
telling the people whom to vote for or
what to do it's about
supporting the people that in these
countries opt for civil society for
liberty for freedom who stand up who
have the
the the courage to do so these people
feel let down
completely by the european union and as
isis can turn
up wherever in the world they feel we
have to really go back to the conditions
of these people and how they live and to
not have these have these
conditions being abused let's wrap up
with our central question as hundreds of
jihadists returned from
the eastern battlefields how dangerous
is islamic state
here in germany today on a numeric scale
from one to five with five being
extremely dangerous how would you rate
the danger threat
amir can we say it is a question we
should
answer it in two parts one of them they
are still
dangerous some of them they are not
especially the children
but in the end of the day we should work
in the long term on this
question one to five what's your rating
danger level
five five i would say three we shouldn't
demonize them
we should take the chance to work with
the ones who are ready to do so the
other ones we have to put in jail
three great finals okay if you want to
rate
uh give us your rating drop in with the
comments
on our youtube feed follow us on twitter
give us your rating there how dangerous
is is in germany right now what do you
think we'd like to hear from you i'm
brian thomas
for all the guests thanks so much for
joining us and so long
[Music]
you